john doe asks would gnome ever consider  giving sam harris a televised discussion  on the role of religion and the us  military adventurism in creating the  present situation in the middle east  well i often have  discussions on these matters  i don't know about televised television  doesn't do these things but on  podcasts on programs like this  constantly discussing  questions of this kind  had a couple this morning in fact  should it be with sam harris  i don't know why i  the little i know about him i don't  think it would be a very valuable  discussion  but i'm involved in them all the time  and i  of course they select only a small  fraction  i mean i have enough invitations to  for a 96-hour day easily  so i have to pick just a few  and  pick my priorities i picked this one not  other ones it's my judgment about what's  value to pursue and  without  wanting to comment on sam harris from  the little i know about him it hasn't  seemed to me worth pursuing  you